[Music]
okay this is as good a place as any to
begin Isla matin serous it's relatively
stable yeah you can you can get your
feet wet here and you should just diving
into the deep end of the pool is where
the big Angry hungry things are and you
want to be ready before you try that and
so so it begins again the machination is
of the ambitious undoing extinction
playing with nature's laws what can
possibly go wrong
come on doctor you know we've learned so
much and invested even more in our
Jurassic operation since the last time
yes mr. Finch yes the the last time
there's always the last time and a next
okay now look I'm Cabot Finch public
relations and crisis management and I'm
here to help you let's focus on what
you're here to do which is create
dinosaur facilities on the islands we
call the five deaths actually last Cinco
Muertos because Spanish is the lingo of
choice around here you'll start by
building a Hammond creation lab we've
already started on an enclosure for you
you should just attach it to the side
but watch out for dinosaurs just kidding
but seriously
obviously you'll need to connect it to
the pre-existing network of paths and
the power grid
now comes the real test incubating a
dinosaur you'll start with a
struthiomimus a big word for a not so
little egg get one by clicking on the
lab and then selecting an egg slot there
should be enough genome data for a
viable dinosaur this also lets me
evaluate your viability so you know no
pressure or anything
your job is simple really create
dinosaurs which attract visitors to your
facilities brings in capital money huh
which means you can do more research to
build better facilities and create more
dinosaurs and there you go a circle of
life development and resources nature
and Commerce say simple
[Music]
life begins the most precious moment the
result of incalculable actions and
reactions trials and errors genetic
mutations and unknowable combinations
chaos all leading to a living breathing
thinking being an entity distinct and
unique and now we you just manufacture
them so well done I guess your facility
is now open and it looks like you are
attracting paying guests which are
really my favorite kind of guests
[Music]
the Hammond Foundation has three main
areas of interest security entertainment
and science
I've already nudged the heads of each
division to reach out to you personally
they'll offer opportunities and
incentives for you to be part of their
team choose one of their contracts it'll
help you develop your facility
hey I'm Isaac I've been hearing good
things about you I'm in charge of the
entertainment division here what good is
the world's greatest show if no one sees
it don't answer it's rhetorical and
painfully obvious what I'm saying is
that we need people in our parts fill up
our facilities with warm bodies numbers
bring revenue excitement and
opportunities
[Music]
an expedition center will allow you to
send dig teams around the world in
search of new Dino fossils DNA can be
extracted from these fossils which our
scientists can then turn into living
breathing dinosaurs and that's our true
lifeblood so one more thing your
reputation your rep quote unquote keep
an eye on it okay
if you have a solid reputation with a
division you're more likely to benefit
from them financially I mean but like
life it's a balancing act each division
is vying for your attention
and if they don't get it they tend to
take it personally tada the
entertainment division is taking notice
of your success as your reputation
increases with them so too does the
opportunity to tackle more arduous
missions hey it's Isaac how you doing I
got some cool stuff you need to be a
part of so I'm putting it out there come
on and help the winning team my
all right look I am all about the show
with these dinosaurs we have one unlike
any other on the planet be parks rely on
drawing people in and what is more
attractive than you dinosaurs
well me of course yeah
know what I'm saying is let's get some
fresh dinos in the hopper we need some
new dinosaurs get to it then we can
create some magic good your first
expedition team is out they'll bring
back what they find to the fossil center
for extraction
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and now we reach the inevitable life
baguettes death but here's the question
that you got to ask yourself was this
avoidable the answer of course not death
it's always coming but could you have
delayed it well that's maybe another
story